hey there guys yes we have finally done
it we're a hundred thousand subscribers
thank you so much for your support and
for helping me get to this point this is
a huge moment for me I'm extremely proud
and pleased yeah I can't wait to get
that silver play button that's something
that no one can ever take away from you
now even if the channel gets deleted
tomorrow I'll have proof that I made it
and here we are so this is our
celebration video and here I'm going to
answer some frequently asked questions
I'm also going to talk a little bit
about the channel in general I've got
some big announcements to make also so
stay tuned
okay so frequently asked questions first
of all how do I train I get this one all
the time knots we want me to share my
training program the main reason I
haven't so far is that it's changing all
the time I'm always incorporating
different aspects and ideas and concepts
into my training and the reason for this
is partly the bionaire i'm always
researching things that i find really
interesting and then when i find
something i want to introduce it into my
programs then really know the way our
train is somewhat similar to reverse
pyramid training power building and with
an awful lot of drop sets so basically
this means that i'll take whatever is
the heaviest or the most difficult or
the most nervous system intensive
exercises stick them at the beginning of
my workouts and then i'll move on
through to things that are more isolated
or a little bit easier or even cardio
and usually I'll do this in a push-pull
legs routine so I'm pushing one day that
means doing anything that involves the
pecs the triceps the shoulders I'm
pulling another day and then I'm doing
my legs and I also do the core my abs on
the legs day or sometimes on the pull
day because actually they fit together
really nicely you're doing things like
hanging leg raises
so to begin the workout I'll do my big
lifts if I'm gonna do that kind of thing
if I'm in the gym or I might do some
calisthenics maybe some plants
progressions or some front lever then
I'm gonna move on to stuff this they're
still quite intensive but not as much
there may be lunge walking or farmers
walks or maybe chin-ups or rope climbs
then I'll move on to stuff that's you
know more isolation and finally I'll do
things that are cardio based or
metabolic resistance so things like the
battle rope for instance or crawls where
I'm going more for distance or for the
maximum number of reps when I do this
I'll target the same muscle group and
that really creates a lot of pump after
you've just hit it with heavy movements
a lot of the time like I say I'll be
doing drop sets mechanical drop sets
they'll also incorporate changes in pace
and things so for instance I might do as
many chin-ups as I can then drop then
start doing curls then I might switch to
hammer curls then I might be cheat curls
and I might do burns
and by doing all this in a row with no
rest in between you not only create a
load of pump and stimulate a lot of
growth and it's fun but at the same time
you actually are using your muscles and
quite a functional weight because you're
training for must
Durance say you're improving the ability
to go for long time using strength and
at the same time we also doing a little
bit of cardio because you're not
allowing sufficient recovery making it
into a kind of metabolic resistance
thing and at the same time you do
actually incorporate the fast twitch
muscle fibers because the slower twitch
ones
fatigue so I just really like training
like this and it allows me to
incorporate all these different ideas
into my training however I like and then
right at the end I'll be something weird
like training my neck or my lungs etc as
I talked about on the channel I also
like to incorporate lots of incidental
training tips throughout the day all
these and the weird like just doing
pistol squats in the kitchen was the
kettles boiling I often like to do my
mobility work in the shower just to save
a lot of time and that's a big focus for
me at the moment being a new dad I don't
have a lot of time and so I'm training
really whenever I can and that also
includes splitting my workouts down into
slightly smaller chunks more modular
things so I'll actually often do just a
big mechanical drop set of biceps in ten
to twelve minutes and that would just be
my biceps workout for those next few
days decides to break my workouts up
into lots of different pieces and
thereby fit them in around the
constantly changing hectic lifestyle I
don't get the recovery I want at the
moment it's hard work but I love it so I
keep doing it a lot of people who also
had questions about the book super
functional training of course if you
want to learn more about my training
that's basically the kind of thing that
I outline in that book so if that sounds
cool that's what that is super
functional training is predominantly one
big PDF which is the book combined with
a training program those are some other
extra materials in there like some
appendices etc now I have also teased
something new coming to the channel and
that's the bio matrix I created that
really short video what is the bio
matrix so basically the bio matrix is a
concept where I'm going to create more
than one channel so the pioneer channel
is a little bit higgledy-piggledy all
over the place I think you can probably
agree sometimes I'm talking about
strength training sometimes I'm talking
about superheroes sometimes I'm talking
about working online the pioneer isn't
gonna change I'm gonna keep everything
pretty much as it is but I'm gonna tone
down the business side of things and the
working online side of things and I'm
gonna be releasing a new channel to
focus on that called the bio matrix but
there are going to be more in the future
I have one in particular planned I'm
going to take away from the biennial I'm
gonna work on that I'm a dip
time when I wouldn't have been working
on the bi-linear anyway so there'll be
no less content here they'll just be
more focused and anything related to
business or technology will be over at
the bio matrix you want to work online
learn to program learn to use tools like
WordPress like illustrator like blender
if you want to learn all the skills to
work online and earn money then yes stay
tuned because I'll be making a
mountainous about that it's coming very
soon I'll share a logo seen a lot of
people asked if grant is coming back and
depending on which came out first you
might have already seen him he's
contributed to my recent Bruce Lee video
and he'll be around he's very busy he's
got his own stuff going on and whenever
we can get him to work on the channel
I'm gonna be doing my best because I
think he's fantastic another question a
lot of people tend to ask me is can I
train them and training is something
that I will be offering at some point in
the future through the site a lot of
people ask me if I can write them a
training program unfortunately I can't
be writing everybody training programs
for free I just don't have time in the
day I would love to I really enjoy it
but you know I have a lot of work to do
another common question that people ask
me is I'm injured in XY area do you have
any tips and my answer there
unfortunately is no I tend to just
ignore those questions out of you know
embarrassment I'm not a physiotherapist
I'm not a doctor I'm not a chiropractor
these are not my areas of interest and I
am studying extra personal training
qualifications at the moment but they
don't cover that kind of thing that's
really not my raiment and so I don't
want to give advice when I don't really
know I'm talking about and especially
when I can't see to even you know assess
the injury or the problem in person so
unfortunately I can't help you with that
I do recommend you see a doctor or
professional in person and don't put it
off because you know you can develop
compensatory movement pattern you can
see your muscle atrophy not that I'm
judging I ignore my injuries all the
time my finger is still really damaged a
lot of people ask me what I do on a day
to day basis how it got started etc so a
little bit about that I work one day
week on the bi-linear full-time now
which is fantastic that I've been able
to do that thanks to you guys it doesn't
earn as much money as my other endeavor
but it's growing and a lot since the
training program and the more it grows
the more time I can dedicate to it so
yeah hopefully it keeps going because
I'd love to do this on an increasingly
more full-time basis I also write for
Angela poverty as many of you know and
have made videos for them in the past so
I go and get our events for them that's
a fantastic job as well and I love doing
that it's another area that I'm
interested in basically Fitness and
Technology on top of that to kind of
bootstrap those interests I've always
been a writer a freelance writer and I
just sell my copywriting and my blogging
to websites to businesses that are
interested in seeing it the channel
itself actually began life as Adam
Snitsky com
I won a competition on bodybuilding.com
team bodybuilders a month and someone
approached me from that and offered to
build me a website for free in exchange
for them keeping the revenue from
advertising
I had a friend meanwhile he ought to
earn money online at the time he held
the top spot on Google from making money
online and he taught me how to monetize
this site then I did a placement from
the University writing for a magazine
called writers news where I'm the lot
about writing and you know how to do
that correctly and whilst I was there
and my spare time cuz I was living in
another city I worked on my new website
called the bio matrix dotnet which of
course I'm bringing back now however
back then the bio matrix was one site
and was basically the same thing as the
bio near and it evolved to become the
bio near eventually at to delete the bio
matrix so I made some mistakes for the
Pioneer as it is today started life
about six or seven years ago it's been
around a long time and it does take a
long time to build momentum yeah I love
what I do here so much I love this topic
I love the feedback from you guys you've
all been fantastic like everyone's like
YouTube is such a toxic place for
comments etc but over here you guys have
been like fantastic
everyone is so positive and uplifting
and you're always giving me ideas to me
topics and this has really helped me to
just stick at it even when I was getting
very few views just the interest from
you guys and the feedback and the fact
that I love studying this stuff so much
I'm writing about it honestly I'll do it
for free but then I won't be able to do
it as much so I'm hoping it continues to
grow in this vein and that's why I'm so
excited to have reached a hundred
thousand subscribers and it's why I'm so
excited about all the stuff that I'm
bringing to the channel
the final thing I'm gonna be doing to
celebrate this milestone is just
touching on all the topics again that
you guys have enjoyed the most and that
have been the most successful so I'm
gonna be talking about Batman I'm gonna
be doing a new Batman training program
for 2020 because that's one of the
biggest and most popular videos on this
site so why not and I've learned a whole
lot more that we can incorporate into
that I'm gonna be returning to old-time
strong man training because there's lots
more lifts and things I've discovered
that I use a lot and lots more reasons
to do all-time strong mind training like
it's great I'm gonna be returning to
Bruce Lee or I already have like I said
I can't remember what audio this is
gonna go out and invest it gonna try and
release this when we hit hundred
thousand and this one's gonna be Bruce
Lee's training program as it would be
today for someone who could actually do
it and it's gonna be featuring Grant so
of course it's gonna be a little bit
more knowledgeable in the muesli
Department I'm also going to be touching
on lots of other new subjects I think
you guys gonna find really interesting
I've got one called project Superman on
the way I've got one called the bane
protocol I won't spoil what those things
are about just now I'm going to be
talking about glute training because
that's an important one that I really
need to cover and meditation because
that gets a lot of requests I'm gonna be
focusing on balance I'm gonna be doing a
parkour workout because why haven't I
done that already that's an awesome
topic I'm gonna be doing military and
special operations units training from
all around the world because again lots
of requests on that one
Wow I blabbered on for so long there
that I ran out of memory on my memory
card and I had like 8 gigabytes yeah
lots of nice stuff come to the channel
just to summarize I'll be talking more
about the bio matrix and future got lots
of cool videos on the way and the main
takeaway is just I'm incredibly grateful
to you guys for making this possible and
I'm so stoked to be a hundred thousand
and I'm so happy with the way this
channel is going so thank you so much
and yeah subscribe if you want more like
this if you haven't already you know why
not be the hundred thousand and once
person and I'll see you next time thanks
ton for watching bye for now
[Music]
you